Voiceover:So we've got 3 Y
squared plus 6 X to the third
and we're raising this
whole to the fifth power
and we could clearly
use a binomial theorem
or pascal's triangle in order
to find the expansion of that.
But what I want to do
is really as an exercise
is to try to hone in on
just one of the terms
and in particular I want to
hone in on the term that has
some coefficient times X to
the sixth, Y to the sixth.
So in this expansion some term
is going to have X to
the sixth, Y to sixth
and I want to figure
out what the coefficient
on that term is and I
encourage you to pause
this video and try to
figure it out on your own.
So I'm assuming you've had
a go at it and you might
have at first found this to
be a little bit confusing.
I'm only raising it to the fifth power,
how do I get X to the
sixth, Y to the sixth?
But then when you look at the actual terms
of the binomial it starts
to jump out at you.
Okay, I have a Y squared term,
I have an X to the third term,
so when I raise these to
powers I'm going to get,
I could have powers higher
than the fifth power.
But to actually think about which of
these terms has the X to
the sixth, Y to the sixth,
let's just look at the pattern in,
in I guess the actual expansion
without even thinking
about its coefficients.
And we've seen this multiple times before
where you could take your
first term in your binomial
and you could start it off
it's going to start of at a,
at the power we're taking
the whole binomial to
and then in each term it's going
to have a lower and lower power.
So let me actually just
copy and paste this.
So this is going to be, so copy
and so that's first term, second term,
let me make sure I have enough space here.
Second term, third term,
fourth term, fourth term,
fifth term, and sixth term it's
going to have 6 terms to it,
you always have one more
term than the exponent.
And then, actually before I
throw the exponents on it,
let's focus on the second term.
So the second term, actually
I'll write it like this.
So the second term's
times 6 X to the third,
let me copy and paste that, whoops.
So let me copy and paste that.
So we're going to put that there.
That there.
And that there.
And then over to off your screen.
I wrote it over there.
We'll see if we have to go there.
And then let's put the exponents.
So this exponent, this is going to be
the fifth power, fourth
power, third power,
second power, first
power and zeroeth power.
And for the blue expression,
for 6 X to the third,
this is going to be the
zeroeth power, first power,
first power, second power,
third power, fourth power,
and then we're going to have
the fifth power right over here.
Then and, of course, they're each going
to have coefficients in front of them.
They're each going to have
coefficients in front of them.
So there's going to be a
coefficient in front of this one,
in front of this one, in front of this one
and then we add them all together.
But which of these terms is
the one that we're talking about.
Has X to the sixth, Y to the sixth.
So here we have X, if we
take Y squared to the fourth
it's going to be Y to the
eighth, so that's not it.
if we go here we have Y
squared to the third power,
that's Y to the sixth and here you have
X to the third squared,
that X to the sixth.
So what we really want to think about
is what is the coefficient,
what is the coefficient
in front of this term, in
front of this term going to be?
Essentially if you put it
in this way it's going to be
the third term that we
actually care about.
So what is this coefficient going to be?
Now we have to clear, this coefficient,
whatever we put here that we can use
the binomial theorem to figure
out isn't going to be this,
this thing that we have to,
I guess our actual solution
to the problem that we
posed is going to be
the product of this coefficient
and whatever other
coefficients we have over here.
Cause we're going to have 3 to
the third power, six squared.
So we're going to have to
figure out what that is.
But let's first just figure
out what this term looks like,
this term in the expansion.
What this yellow part actually is.
And there's a couple of
ways that we can do that.
We could use Pascal's triangle
or we could use combinatorics.
If we use combinatorics we know that
the coefficient over here,
this is going to be 5 choose 0,
this is going to be the coefficient,
the coefficient over here
is going to be 5 choose 1.
We've seen this multiple times.
You could view it as essentially
the exponent choose the the top,
the 5 is the exponent that we're raising
the whole binomial to and
we say choose this number,
that's the exponent on the
second term I guess you could say.
So this would be 5 choose 1.
And this one over here, the
coefficient, this thing in yellow.
This is going to be 5, 5 choose 2.
5 choose 2.
Now what is 5 choose 2?
Well that's equal to 5
factorial over 2 factorial,
over 2 factorial, times,
times 5 minus 2 factorial.
So let me just put that in here.
Times 5 minus 2 factorial.
And this is going to be equal to.
Let's see 5 factorial is
5 times 4 times 3 times 2,
we could write times 1 but
that won't change the value.
Over 2 factorial.
Actually let me just write that
just so we make it clear
it is times 1 there.
2 factorial is 2 times 1 and then what
we have right over here,
this is 3 factorial,
times 3 times 2 times 1.
So let's see this 3
can cancel with that 3,
that 2 can cancel with that
2, the 1's don't matter,
won't change the value and
then 4 divided by 2 is 2.
So that is just 2, so we're left
with 5 times 2 is equal to 10.
So that's going to be this
number right over here.
This is going to be a 10.
Now another we could have done
it is using Pascal's triangle.
We could have said okay
this is the binomial,
now this is when I raise it to
the second power as 1 2
1 are the coefficients.
When I raise it to the third power,
the coefficients are 1, 3, 3, 1.
When I raise it to the fourth power
the coefficients are 1, 4, 6, 4, 1
and when I raise it to the fifth power
which is the one we care
about, the coeffiencients
are going to be 1, 5, 10, 5
or sorry 10, 10, 5, and 1.
And we know that when we go,
this is going to be the third term so
this is going to be the
coefficient right over here.
1, 2, 3, third term.
So either way we know that this is 10.
But now let's try to answer
our original question.
What is this going to be?
What are we multiplying times
X to the sixth, Y to the sixth?
And now we just have to essentially
rewrite this expression.
So it's going to be 10
times 3 to the third power,
3 to the third power, times
Y squared to the third power,
which is Y squared to the third
power is Y to the sixth power.
Y to the sixth power.
Times six squared so
times six squared times X
to the third squared which
that's X to the 3 times 2
or X to the sixth and so
this is going to be equal to.
Let's see it's going to be
10 times 27 times 36 times 36
and then we have, of course,
our X to the sixth and Y to the sixth.
So this is going to be, essentially,
let's see 270 times 36 so let's see,
let's get a calculator out.
270, I could have done it by
hand but I'll just do this
for the sake of time, times 36 is 9,720.
So that's the coefficient right over here.
It's going to be 9,720 X to
the sixth, Y to the sixth.
9,720 X to the sixth, Y to
the sixth and we're done.